What did we study in our last lesson?
We studied about meristematic tissues,
right?
Now tell me one thing, do plants also have
permanent tissues right when they
germinate from seeds?
Permanents tissues are composed of cells that
have
lost the power of dividing.
That is kind of out of place, right?
The plant is growing and thus MUST have
only meristematic tissues.
Permanent tissues would mean tissues that
are
already present and those that DO NOT divide.
So initially if the plant does not
have PERMANENT tissues, where do they come
into the picture?
I am sure this is a mind-boggling question!
The answer is actually quite simple.
When meristematic tissues have divided and
reached the final stage of
division, they attain maturity.
After this point, these tissues do not divide
anymore.
They only get differentiated into different
parts and these non-
dividing tissues then become PERMANENT tissues.
Did you understand what
this means?
It means both the meristematic tissues and
permanent tissues are
one and the same.
When tissues grow and divide, they are known
as
meristematic tissues.
And when they finally mature and divide no
more, they
become permanent tissues.
So permanent tissues are nothing but MATURED
meristematic tissues.
Do you
know there are mainly two types of permanent
tissues?
Can you take a guess
at their names?
Yes, they are SIMPLE tissues and COMPLEX tissues.
We will
look at the ‘simple permanent tissues’
in detail.
The very word ‘SIMPLE’ means they have
very a simple structure.
All the cells
of a simple permanent tissue are almost the
same.
Do you know that there are
three subtypes of the simple permanent tissue?
Yes, and do you want to know
what they are called?
PARENCHYMA, COLLENCHYMA and SCLERENCHYMA are
the three types of
simple permanent tissues.
If you must know in one word what each of
these
tissues do, let us see what they can be called
otherwise.
Parenchyma can be
called a ‘filler’ tissue; Collenchyma
is a ‘supporter’ while sclerenchyma is
a
‘protector’ tissue.
We will look at each of these tissues in detail
in our coming videos.
Stay tuned!